[Música]
en la imagen pueden observar
pero necesita esto para que sea más
claro en esta imagen pueden observar a
una mujer que está con tres computadoras
auriculares que utiliza el transcriptor
utiliza todo tipo de accesibilidad de
herramientas que nos pueden servir esta
es la situación de las personas con
discapacidad auditiva
una persona acústica como pueden
observar y bueno ustedes como podrán ver
esta realidad de la pandemia nos ha
hecho reflexionar sobre cómo nosotros
podemos implementar las distintas formas
de actividad de herramientas
y como nosotros podemos aprovechar estas
crisis como una gran oportunidad poder
hoy implica que en países de ingresos
medios y bajos
era muy costosos no hay médicos
un tiempo de conseguirles audífonos
estoy entre esas personas que dejaron
para conseguirlo a un precio más barato
en la distribuidora me fui a méxico
congreso de dirección de proyectos
la situación de los audífonos implica
que tienes que escoger una marca de
proceder iniciar sesión en esta marca y
tomando en cuenta que volviendo tenemos
que calibrar esta marca
el especialista que trabaja en tareas
estos son los que no podemos escuchar
pero también hay los que nos quieren
escuchar son personas que pueden estar
muy cunas donde el volumen a un volumen
de más de 70 decibelios
van a estar teniendo
durante más de tres horas y les va a
afectar la visión tenemos generaciones
que están siendo jóvenes pero con oído
de sotomayor y dentro de esta situación
les voy a mencionar algunas de esas
vivencias por ejemplo yo estoy en un
curso con trabajo
y yo digo perdón no escuchar también en
grupo
no he tenido por repetir no no es nada
te dijo tonterías
asegura la fecha nos explicará por qué
quitarle que con día anestesia en
situación muy cotidiana que podemos
pasar nosotros pero que estamos ya
acostumbrados ahora yo les vestir una
pregunta
que estar no ver a nadie seguramente
muchos de ustedes me van a decir
piénselo bien me van a decir no es bueno
decir no vez entonces este es el interés
selic que les dice entren a ver y nadie
pero si no y por qué por qué no ver
decide ten comunica de las otras
empresas pero no hoy
en comunicar a las personas y esto se
convierte en objeto este es mi
existencial es muy filosófico nos damos
cuenta de que esto lo dijo el interior
hasta decirles atrás siendo periodistas
activistas feministas han luchado por
los derechos de las personas con
discapacidad la situación ha cambiado
mucho para los cerveceros
pero ya ustedes continuando
parafraseando la que ya no puede hacerlo
todo pero tipo de hace algo y mientras
que puede hacer algo para luchar por
conseguirlo por este derecho muchos
tenemos esos derechos nosotros podemos
observar la situación de los sordociegos
en américa latina dos historias en el
vida mencionar la de álex de brasil ser
de ciego total tiene un resto de vista
y a pesar de esto ha podido viajar por
todo el mundo al llegar a naciones
unidas a luchar por sus derechos a hacer
conocer la ceguera asistir a la
situación de américa latina que es un
infierno y esa muestra de cristal la
situación no ha cambiado mucho desde
entonces
álex tiene una amiga que te ama la wta
la ahora era a personas como cualquiera
de verdad es que también en esta vida
laura ha perdido por un asma parte de
batista parte de la visión la wta and
encía de orejas en herat ex ella tiene
una situación de una barrera
podemos comunicarnos por escrito también
comunicación por lengua de señas actriz
tania anal por la palma de la mano
como álex es saber español inglés
portugués
esta accesibilidad de garantiza
poder desplazarse con autonomía a pesar
de que no tiene limpias internet
esto es para darle una edad hoy en día
existe en modelos sociales y de derechos
de las personas con discapacidad en qué
consiste la convención de los derechos
de las personas con discapacidad es
establecer el año 2006 que nosotros no
estamos que el problema el problema está
en la interacción entre nosotros las
personas con discapacidad con el interno
el entorno que nos puede la larga y
cuyos ajustes razonables garantizan la
igualdad de oportunidades con los demás
la equidad de condiciones con las
personas sin discapacidad
nosotros para llegar hasta tenemos que
ir luchando en nuestros respectivos
países para que nuestros derechos sean
escuchados conocer nuestros derechos en
la imagen que vemos en la pantalla hay
distintos tipos de discapacidad
distintas necesidades hay una historia
detrás de cada una de ellas y le puedo
mencionar un ejemplo de cómo las
personas con discapacidad pueden estar
incluidas
y también dentro de la paz de la que es
la diversidad de manos sólo vamos a
mencionar la diversidad auditiva porque
es lo que me compete como un poco si
existen varias identidades el oyente
el cerdo
el hipo acústico del rey y político
entre el cerdo y la gente externa h en
lengua de señas estrella al media y por
lo tanto entre dos mundos
entonces hay las personas sordas las
personas sordociegas totales y parciales
cada uno con sus respectivos tipos de
necesidades de los escucha muy fuerte en
fundido
y bueno también hay diferentes tipos de
descendido
ahora también existen diferentes tipos
de platos la plaza de la gente
de la plasta del sordo más alto más
fuerte
mezclados
y este de la plancha del cerdo se va
es válida porque hay porque se siente la
vibración porque al no tener vista a la
audición se siente por el cuerpo las
vibraciones por el tacto que es el
último recurso en esta imagen que
ustedes pueden ver en la pantalla hay
cuatro personas con discapacidad y un
perdía y vamos a decirlo con el nombre y
el tipo de discapacidad para no darle
muchas vueltas
allí te encuentras víctor con
discapacidad psicosocial mariana con
discapacidad visual y si más sí pero ya
hay varios tipos de perro de asistencia
pero es la carilla fermín de personas
con discapacidad físico-motora hay
varios tipos de ajuste de las mates de
accesibilidad en mecanismos y uno de
ellos es la verdad motorizada también
existen los audífonos implante coclear
de las personas que están allí en
alergias se extiende la plata evento
musical en los otros estación de la
plaza del cerdo fermín no tiene
motricidad es tetrapléjica entonces no
pudo hacer la plaza
esto es parte de la diversidad
demandante y bien nuestros derechos y
que consisten en estos tres hay una
frase que se suele vestir en el
movimiento de los derechos de las
personas con discapacidad nada sobre
nosotros sin nosotras porque nuestros
derechos no se negocian en nuestra
habilidad no tiene precio
ahora les pongo un ejemplo una señora
una madre de un hipo acústico le
preguntó al otro día que es cómo puede
hacer ya para qué se hizo esperar
partida bien porque me llames como un
modelo y eligiendo señora yo no soy una
inspiración yo solamente esta necesidad
violenta que no respeta los que
funcionamos distintos nosotros tenemos
que saber de nuestras derechas y
ejercerlos
entonces la que yo les puedo recomendar
es
a través de otro ejemplo la mente el eje
músico algún resto de dirección de
proyectos sistemas de celulares el
taller en inglés
este taller estaba que yo no puede
escuchar muy de cerca con el parlante
por la situación en la que me encuentro
y aún así tengo ocurrió en el último
momento aplicar esta fórmula
de bien que hemos visto el caso de la
hora que atraviesan a una cuarentena
permanente también aires
cuatro palabras trípoli
aplicar al respecto de lo que podría ser
la inclusión
está la creatividad está la empatía está
la inercia y está la paciencia
entonces hemos utilizado esos tres
celulares con la creatividad en la
paciencia hemos puesto en inglés escrito
el parlante hemos puesto un celular para
cambiar el texto de lo que está en
inglés escrito español escrito y no me
perdí en nada de las conferencias que
incluso había personas de tres sistemas
que tenían dificultad para comprender no
y es así como se tiene que resolver
muchas barreras con creatividad con
entusiasmo aplicar eso oyente tenemos
todas las herramientas estas
reposiciones de enseñar a esta madre de
este niño y el reciento de niños que
están
luchando por incluirlos cree en ti mismo
ha de evitar con determinación honor y
valentía
muchas gracias